le docteur pêche y est il le plus grand
empoisonneurs en série de l'histoire où
la victime d'une effarante erreur
judiciaire
il est en tout cas au coeur d'une
enquête qui prend un tour spectaculaire
quelque part dans le jura les corps de
deux hommes et deux femmes décédées dans
des circonstances troubles ont été
exhumés aux fins de topsy un acte
exceptionnel dans la culture judiciaire
française qui ont 20 à l'exhumation
ça veut dire que des données dans tête
et que d'éventuelles données
scientifiques ont amené le certains
experts ou certains enquêteurs à dire au
parquet il est nécessaire que nous
procédions à l'exhumation
l'exhumation les excitations peut-être
ne donneront rien changé il ya parfois
des poisons qu'on ne retrouve pas sur
des dépouilles il ya des données
scientifiques parfois qui permettent ou
non de découvrir qu'il y ait un poison
au coeur d'une instruction qui lui a
valu d'être mise en examen pour sept cas
suspects dont deux mortels
l'anesthésiste de la clinique
saint-vincent fait également l'objet
d'une enquête préliminaire en théorie
secrète qui elle s'intéresse à 42 autres
cas les quatre exhumation demandés sont
elles les premières d'une longue série
où les seuls qui pose vraiment question
pour la défense elles sont surtout
l'oeuvre d'une machine judiciaire qui
enquête à charge et s'enfonce on est
capable d'aller jusqu'au bout du bout
pour essayer de démontrer si ou de
trouver quelque chose contre le docteur
péché même s'il n'ya pas je vais vous
dire une chose si le dossier était si
parfait à l'instruction en termes de
preuves aujourd'hui aucune preuve contre
le docteur pêcheurs s'il était si
parfait en termes de preuves entre le
docteur péché on n'aurait pas eu besoin
d'essayer ou de chercher absolument
d'autres cas pour essayer de corroborer
l'hypothèse du départ et julie hypothèse
folle du départ des enquêteurs les
analyses scientifiques déboucheront tel
sur des mises en examen supplémentaire
la défense se dit sereine
quoi qu'il en soit il est aujourd'hui
des familles qui pensait avoir fait leur
deuil et qui doute tout à coup